welcome to deconstructing chatbots I am
Priyanka Vergara and in today's episode
we are going to explore how to integrate
dialogue flow with telephony gateway the
other day I was talking to a friend
about chatbots and he said Priyanka it
would really help me if I could just
decide a phone number to the chat bot
that I already have built that way I can
provide the same experience to my users
across the phone and web well that led
me to this episode so today we are going
to work with the same appointment
scheduler chat bot that we built in the
previous episodes and integrated with
the telephony gateway so our users
calling on the phone can get the same
experience as the ones in the web now
remember that this is a feature in beta
so you may want to let us know how
you're using it so that we can keep
improving it let's get in our dialogue
flow console and locate our agent
appointment scheduler with our intents
we are going to go into integration
section very enabled our web and Google
home integration this time we will
select dialogue flow phone gateway it
allows you to select the country for the
phone number and in next step you choose
the phone number I'm good with the
default selection and we'll just finish
it here once you finish you see the
congratulations message indicating a
phone number that's assigned to your bot
for your users to call in now as you can
see in yellow the phone number you get
is valid only for 30 days if you're
using Standard Edition if you're a
business you definitely want a permanent
number so for that you should be using
Enterprise Edition let's place a call to
our bot at 267 to eight one five one
five nine which is the number that we
assigned hello how can I help you
schedule an appointment for 4:00 p.m.
tomorrow what services are you looking
to get DMD offers driver license and
vehicle registration services driver's
license you are all set for you driver's
license on the 25th of January 2019 at
16 hours 0 minutes and 0 seconds see you
that all right so my friend is really
happy now that he can just assign a
phone number to his chat bot and provide
the same experience across web and phone
channels don't miss the next episode of
deconstructing chat BOTS because we are
going to learn more about entities if
you liked this video and would like to
see more of this content then please
like and subscribe to our Channel
[Music]